should imagine me at an orgy hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to slime rancher we're
currently uh where we're not supposed to
be we're breaking the game here and I do
not know what the hell that is but I do
not think I can reach that it's going to
see I'm gonna do a test to see how much
distance I can actually cover in one jet
pack do daddy hip know but evidently a
little it's a considerable distance but
I don't know if that was that much of a
distance and I'd hate to come all this
way
oh that's it eight squeeze ah oh man and
if I get there what would I do I
wouldn't be able to get back so let's
not end this in this adventure so
quickly as to throw myself off a place
where I'm not supposed to go maybe later
on in the episode I'll go back over
there but for now I'm really trying just
to get back home cuz I'm trapped on an
island with people that I don't know and
it's all going horribly a wrong and here
we go okay so now that I got six honey
slime I'll be able to feed the honey
slime whatever the hell the honey slime
eat and then I'll be able to make rich
delicious honey poops that I'll be able
to sell on the market for a premium
because I'm the poop master
I'm the poop extraordinaire I am the God
of all poop
I am the the CEO of poop incorporated I
am the man these titles just aren't
getting any better as I go along
I'm doing my best ok bye kitty man oh
hello where the hell'd you come from
okay either way so I just gotta get back
again hey I need you oh i need you i
need chickens that's what I need I need
I need chickens because I need to start
collecting them for the big cat so that
I can get another thing because I'm
willing to bet there's another key there
are another gate locked farther in that
would be more than happy to accept some
meat and I'm not eating a lot of it
judging by how much the pink slime the
Largo pink slime needed and it was a lot
of food but once I get these honey back
my first focus we'll be able to get more
money because there's things on the
sides of my farm that I haven't really
addressed yet
the reason I haven't addressed him is
because I have no idea what they do and
so I'm gonna go home and find out what
they do and then you guys are gonna
believe that I'm smart and then it's
gonna all work out better for me and
then the opinion of me on the Internet
is gonna go slightly up but for now it's
very low and I'm okay with that for now
all right let's see what these do all
right
proceed activate rants very own Lanza Oh
oh that's lovely learn more the
overgrowth is an expansion to the ranch
that is covered in moss in tall grass
the thick that it creates allows for
fruits and veggies to grow naturally and
attract the occasional wild chicken
making an ideal space for a rancher that
wants to hell they're twins and roam
more freely okay the grotto is an
expansion to the ranch set inside a
slightly spooky cave that a lot of the
ranchers care for life sensitive wine
but other needs for a whole screen
never has a phosphor fine fellow
liberated okay ah oh I should build the
coop ooh wait there's more world oh cool
oh cool there's so much about this world
that I don't know man there's a lot of
stuff that I don't know but I'm gonna
find it out here ventually and
eventually with your help because I'm
this is the only episode that I'm gonna
record without getting you guys as
instructions on what I'm supposed to do
for the rest of it so definitely
definitely tell me what I'm doing wrong
because I know for a gosh darn fact I
definitely am doing things wrong here
I'm not going about it the most
efficient way oh oh yeah I forgot the
original reason I went out in the last
episode was to find the bright sunshiny
ones but that was definitely not gonna
happen
so let's see how much the cave is either
both fifteen hundred so I don't need
that but what I do need is a chicken
coop if I'm gonna start raising some
chickens so if I raise chickens and then
get some roosters in there with them
that'll be a little bit
No look at that get in there
lay some eggs I just got to get her Oh
God look how was that him real bad hey
stop being so sassy have some friends I
don't know if I think six should be
enough yes it should be more than enough
they shouldn't be able to do yeah
they'll be fine they eat fruit oh yeah
I'm gonna make so much money I'm gonna
make all the money that was actually a
worthwhile trip going all the way out
there phosphors I need you yes thank you
I wonder if the I can't even collect
those there's fatties that merge their
diets to make bigger slimes come here
you
sorry not really hey cool there's tons
of them I guess they only come out at
night and I don't know why the entire
environment isn't being destroyed by
those deadly deadly I god damn it right
on my taint I landed grundle first on
that spikey dick
not literally spikey didn't not whenever
man this whole series I'm saying things
that are absolutely wrong could be
misconstrued in the most horrible ways
does anyone else want to be part of my
horrible trade on the black market
between third parties of unknown ill
repute you'll literally be tortured for
the rest of your days and no one will
ever see their families again now who
wants to come with me oh you oh god you
are not what I was considering you're
way too big ah God stinking I'm trying
to do a thing can you not
Olo that's one of you least Oh rooster
good get out here come here I need you
oh god damn it uh I can least I got the
rooster he's the one with the penis he
can really do damage on this one oh I
gotta get home here make babies mega
babies stop being upside-down you
adorable little rooster I mean you are
really cute but there you go now
Jim get him yeah strut that but stuff
you're made of Nance make more babies
make more babies maybe maybe this isn't
the romantic mood I'm setting for them I
shouldn't be shouting at them to get the
busy on yeah dude yeah yeah get him yeah
I would be terrible at an orgy never
mind just imagine me at an orgy no don't
imagine don't imagine that but I mean
would it be like be bad that's what a
good oh cool it's just that easy and
then they make good food or a good poop
and a great poop I get this cat out of
here he's gonna eat one of the wrong
ports get out of here no one wants you
you stupid cat that's right you got some
distance on you more boobs more poops
poop more put more put more now Boop put
more poop poop more poop dammit poop
Oh boop boop dammit
poop please for me okay there we go how
about run your mouth
oh god dammit don't move away from me
you know you want it eight I'm a
horrible farmer I shove food in the
faces of my captives I think I don't
know another word for it I learned
literally in a prison I forced them to
eat and then I collect all our poop I
really really AM weird
okay what's over here oh I forgot about
this improve nano sores toward CDs oh
good
I want that Oh wonderful I can hold
thirty of things now Oh delightful does
he'll sell my honey ports and I'll make
a ton of money hobble buh buh buh buh
buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh I'm rich
I'm rich off poop on the poop God home
the king of all poop yay
ah-ha-ha-ha damn it I need more fruit I
need more fruit to shoving sadness limes
don't worry everybody I'm just going
into town just buying up all the fruit
from the shopping center don't mind me
your shove these in my swabs
I'm gonna sell their poop it's a racket
that only I can foresee cuz I'm a genius
yeah no one man me crazy markiplier
wandering in god dammit I needed that
okay I'm gonna take these babies cuz you
just totally ate their mother you
smother eat ur mother eaten [ __ ] I'm
sorry I shouldn't use such arse language
mother eatin [ __ ] so I need an
objective that's basically like I really
do need an objective because I'm kind of
just wandering around aimlessly to get
food and stuff for this and I mean
admittedly they're a not be all that
much to the game just yet I wanna steal
your babies but don't worry I'm gonna
take you with me get rid of these tabby
ports boy blink okay so now that I have
that no no save it oh okay got it okay
you have any babies have they been
eating already oh the tragedy oh no I'm
so sad so anyway I need an end objective
and I'm not exactly sure what I should
be doing at the moment but find gas like
I've already explored another island and
I will go back to that eventually I'm
just trying to collect mums at the
moment because I need a lot more money
to get all the upgrades and then expand
my kingdom and that sort of stuff but
what I do need at the end of the day
excuse me my throat a guy got coughed
it's really hard not good I think I'm
okay oh wow that was not easy to hold
that back anyway I need more honey
slimes that's what I need not too many
more or else I'll get away but I need
more honey slimes and maybe I could just
shove them in there and eventually
they'll become
he'd get fat and poop get fat and poop
get fat and poop the 7zi corporation
would like to welcome you to far far
range and extend our support in your
bold venture as a slime rancher we would
look forward to supplying you a steady
flow o supplying us with a steady flow
of Florence of which we'll hand pay
handsomely so I'm just sending these
poop these poops off to an unknown
corporation who's paying me money I
don't know what they're doing with the
poops even though these poops seem to
have some weird metamorphosizing
properties that the other slimes eat the
poops and then something happens I'm not
a hundred percent sure on the science
behind it but something happened oh good
it's about goddamn time y'all started
pooping out some money
duplicate already come on I had the
whole philosophy where you feed a baby
for long enough it makes more babies I
put a bunch of babies in there make more
babies and then they make more babies
that's how it works
what hens eat meat what are you gonna
eat each other that doesn't make any
sense
stop trying to escape okay so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna open the expansion
to the underground cave one because that
sounds really cool yeah I did it I did a
thing I accomplished something in the
zoo whoa cool
oh look at this oh that's so cool and
slightly creepy the description was very
apt whoa dude that's awesome but I
literally could have probably held a
whole bunch of slimes
if I was actually smart I would have uh
I would have created a lot more hens for
slimes to live and then I would be slime
ranching up a huge business and then I'd
have a lot of different creatures but as
as for right now I seem to be dead set
on one but what I could do oh god the
tree isn't even there anymore okay oh
why didn't I put the cat on the other
pen there was another pen over there why
was I so mean to you that I just threw
you across the way well what I can do is
I can put these phosphorus lime in the
cave because I'm pretty sure the foster
like the darkness of it
so there should be good ah hello
generator pond
I guess Corral ah okay oh that makes
more sense I can add upgraded to the
corral dang that's amazing what didn't I
know that oh then I could have put an
air net on the top of it cuz these
bastards are just gonna escape aren't
they yep you probably are hey get in
there whoa
I said get in there okay ah so that's
good enough place and stop this so
there's a lot more that I could do to
ranch better be a better rancher but
then again I'm a terrible person so
we'll see what happens to that but thank
you everybody so much for watching and I
will be reading the comments in this
video very closely so give me
suggestions of what I should do if you
want to see another episode of this
thanks again everybody and as always I
will see you in the next video
a little faster now